I just got back from Europe they really
make fun of us over there that's like
all they do
oh you America it's just so fat uh like
yeah we're doing great why is it a bad
thing how fat we are I think it's cool
it's like impressive more people die in
America of obesity and starvation which
is like hey we did it
how cool are we we're dying from eating
food we go up to heaven some guys like I
starve to death what happened to you
we're like snacks
yeah the McRib is back what do you want
how'd you lose your foot frostbite now
frosting
yeah we're fat I'm so high up on the
food chain one of my friends he only
eats grass-fed beef you realize how
crazy is that means he gets to pick what
he eats eats that's pretty good and
here's the weird thing
cows eat grass that's what we've messed
with our food when something eats what
it's supposed to we brag about it that's
like saying hey you know my
four-year-old is sober
[Music]
father of the year over here
yeah we're fat all my friends are fat
mostly my family's fat I grew up pretty
fat you know I I tried to make fun of
fat people unless they make fun of me
that's when I let it go yeah like all my
fat friends give me [ __ ] one of my frat
friends tell me I have skinny privilege
like privilege something can't be a
privilege if you could do it too alright
I've known you my whole life he used to
be thin that's not a privileges can't be
attained by exercising right if that
were the case then black people take a
Jazzercise class they wouldn't get
pulled over right it'd be that simple
he always condescends to me oh you're so
lucky you're thin lucky you got to work
at it it's hard what the hell I gotta
eat right it sucks
saying you're so lucky your thins like
saying you're so lucky don't have kids
no no I had food and I pulled out it's
like whatever it's easy being skinny
well not really you couldn't do it
comedy
[Music]